foreign
Ty you know Bing stuff and Google for me
I've always had problems making the
first draft it's just a killer yeah and
I know the feeling you know the feeling
I find it helpful in making the first
draft how do you prompt it what would be
an example approach
all different ways and and that's I've
been collecting this and and here's the
thing in the book of spells yes here
here's the thing about it is that this
is an important lesson about technology
is that we have to use it to figure it
out
there's something I call thinkism which
is this Reliance on trying to solve
problems by thinking about them which is
very appealing to people who like to
think okay and you can only go so far
with thinkism because all the things
we're discovering about this none of the
inventors of this had any idea that they
could be used this way that's cool right
and so we're discovering we collectively
by using it or discovering its
capabilities and eventually its Harms
but that's important because this is how
we steer the things and so the problem
with trying to prohibit or turn it off
or ban it is that you don't get to steer
van going back to that metaphor so right
now through use we're uncovering all
these things and I've been trying to
track how people are actually using them
and like for instance chat so here's the
thing these chat models basically what
they generate are wisdom of the crowd
kind of knowledge wisdom of the crowd
was very famous counting the jelly beans
right like if you average all the
attempts by humans to count the number
of jelly beans in a bottle
the best guess the most accurate was
kind of like the average of them and
that's what we're getting with the chat
it's taking everything is written the
plus to the minuses the Geniuses and the
jerks and it's averaging out and that's
what it's giving you is kind of an
average so most of the content generated
by the chats is sort of broadly correct
very kind of average very kind of bland
and a lot of what you're doing with the
intern
is kind of pressing them so one of the
tricks is that you said you can ask for
it to be a little bit snarkier or more
professional so let's say you're
starting
tabula rasa
idea popped into your head in the shower
okay I want to give a rough draft a shot
what is the step number one step number
two so it depends I might I might ask
you to do a summary of what's known
about this tell me everything that knows
about it write a first draft with
bullets those are the five bullet points
could you give a real example an example
you might use I'm trying to think of the
last one I did how Egyptians influenced
Roman architecture I don't know exactly
right you could do that give me the five
bullet points of stuff and then you
could say you could have questions about
some parts you didn't understand or like
expand this bullet one citing more
sources or give me an example of a day
in the life for this or 10 more examples
of how this might play out you could
kind of expand it that way you could
also shrink it in terms of like
summarizing making bullet points or
what's the key takeaway or how much I
wanted to have like a teachable moment
out of this and so you would have all
these kinds of things floating around
and then again it's the internet work
it's like like good but you're not going
to use it you're probably rewriting it
it's maybe give me some ideas I didn't
have or maybe the structure of how it
organized it was that's pretty good for
four of them and so it's a start and for
me it gets you past the breath hold of
the empty bridge for me this is really
big it's just getting going and then you
can also use it later on
I have a friend who writes scripts and
they do show me all the weak plot points
in this
or could you explain that you put the
script in and they'll say what are some
of the contradictory plot points that's
a great use right just you know kind of
like thinking about fiction you can find
internal inconsistency internal
consistencies or or is continuity broken
or things like that
here's something I used my book which
we'll get to
my publisher asked for talking points
[Music]
talking so I said make a list of nine
talking points for this machine number
one for this book woolly mammoth number
two okay and it made a a good list again
I couldn't really use the list but it
was I could use it to make the list the
starting point it was a starting point
and here's another thing so I have a
friend who has a Blog a daily blog they
generate
40 posts a day
okay I can probably guess this probably
who yes it is I was like that's a lot
it's 40 a day so they use it to help
write headlines they'll give a thing and
say give me five headlines now I've
actually not used say Chad GPD for this
there's an upload function where you can
upload your document and then use that
as the basis or part of the basis for
the prompt yeah write some headlines it
says it's really really good with
suggesting something that they hadn't
thought of or he said also sometimes
I'll give it the the little the posting
and said give me a great punchline at
the end
that's cool and again it's the intern
you know the bad you know pretty good
it's going to give you something though
give you something to start with
you know I'll give you an example from
my own life just for fun A friend of
mine suggested this because he sent me a
text he said this is pretty interesting
and he used chat GPT he's been exploring
all these tools in great depth and I've
played with a lot of them but not in the
depth that he has and he had suggested a
podcast guest
John verakee who was on not too long ago
and he simply put in a prompt along the
lines of
what are questions that Tim Ferriss
might ask John verakee on his podcast in
the style of Tim Ferriss and
they weren't perfectly Polished but they
were not bad right exactly and not bad
is I think the title I mean if that's
what we were talking about it's a not
bad intern okay it's still not bad
interns